[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
vamos a ver hoy
el hombre fuerte del chavismo hasta
ahora Intocable pese a tener una orden
de captura estadounidense en su contra
daré que lais a mí renunció a su cargo
como ministro de petróleo en el marco de
una investigación de corrupción dentro
de la petrolera estatal de Venezuela
pedevesa un cambio que sugiere
movimientos en la estructura interna del
Poder del país suramericano
y el expresidente estadounidense Donald
Trump alentó a sus seguidores a salir a
las calles para apoyarlo asegurando que
iba a ser detenido al tiempo que un gran
Jurado se reunía para apenas determinar
si lo acusaba o no por los pagos a la
actriz de cine para adultos stormy
Daniels para que guardara silencio sobre
una relación extramarital que
supuestamente mantuvieron
y visitaremos México donde activistas
alertan del impacto en el medio ambiente
que tiene la deforestación por cuenta de
la construcción del proyecto insignia
del presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador el tren Maya nos lo cuenta la
corresponsal de France 24 en el país
norteamericano
y comenzamos este recorrido por las
historias de nuestro continente en
Venezuela porque el ministro de petróleo
tare que la isamí una de las figuras más
emblemáticas del chavismo renunció a su
cargo luego de que su entorno fuera
salpicado por una investigación de
corrupción dentro de la petrolera
estatal pedevesa el aishamía afirmó que
dimite Para apoyar las pesquisas
adelantadas por el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro en su lugar fue designado el
ingeniero pedrochea la caída del
aissamid es la caída de un veterano
chavista que está en la lista de los más
buscados de Estados Unidos por vínculos
con el narcotráfico veamos más en el
siguiente informe que preparamos para
ustedes
he designado como vicepresidente
ejecutivo de la República bolivariana de
Venezuela al compañero tared el aissami
para que asuma esta nueva etapa
2018 Intocable hasta ahora pared el
aissami uno de los hombres fuertes del
chavismo pese a estar en la mira de
Estados Unidos que los sancionó en 2017
cuando ocupaba la vicepresidencia de
Venezuela por vínculos con el
narcotráfico y lo incluyó en la lista de
los más buscados del servicio de
inmigración y control de aduanas siguió
ocupando altos cargos en Caracas desde
2019 enfrentaba acusaciones de
narcotráfico ante la Corte Federal de
Manhattan a lo que en un simbólico
nombramiento Nicolás Maduro respondió
desigándolo ministro de petróleos en
2020 van a encontrar empresas
productivas
empresas que han sabido resistir
a los embates de estas sanciones
ilegales previo a esto había desempeñado
varios puestos importantes de
nombramiento tanto por parte de maduro
como de Hugo Chávez así como de elección
popular tenemos ya
Constituyente y vamos a tener Dios
mediante
pueblo mediante
la reelección de nuestro hermano Nicolás
Maduro como presidente su ascenso empezó
desde sus estudios en los 90 Cuando se
hizo amigo de Adam Chávez el hermano del
fallecido presidente logró la
gobernación de su estado natal aragua el
Ministerio del interior entre otros a
Venezuela no la sanciona nadie a
nosotros Somos un pueblo
invencible pero participó en política
exterior el aissami fue el propulsor de
los vínculos de Venezuela con Irán Y es
señalado de ayudar a emitir pasaportes
venezolanos para militantes de gez bola
así como de la expansión de la relación
comercial con Turquía en una búsqueda de
rutas para evadir las sanciones
internacionales contra el petróleo
venezolano
vamos Haití para revisar la cifra de la
semana 530 la organización de Naciones
Unidas informó que esa es la cifra de
personas que han sido asesinadas en lo
corrido de 2023 por acciones violentas
de las pandillas tan solo en los
primeros 15 días de marzo 208 personas
fueron Víctimas de homicidio la oficina
de la ONU para los Derechos Humanos
agregó que los miembros de las bandas
también están utilizando la violencia
sexual contra las mujeres y las niñas
para
aterrorizarlas a ellas y a sus familias
y seguimos en Centroamérica esta semana
iniciaron las audiencias en la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos por
el caso de Beatriz contra El Salvador es
la historia de una joven que tenía lupus
a la que en 2013 se le impidió
interrumpir su embarazo pese a la
inviabilidad del feto que iba a nacer
con una malformación las estrictas leyes
contra el aborto en la nación
centroamericana obligan a las mujeres a
seguir adelante con su embarazo si no
pueden asumir condenas de hasta 50 años
de prisión ahora la corte puede sentar
un precedente que obligue al Estado
salvadoreño a cambiar esta Norma pues El
Salvador reconoce la jurisdicción de la
corte idh Aunque la decisión no se
espera antes de finales de 2023 Marta
Moya tiene más detalles
una vigilia de esperanza
[Música]
decenas de mujeres de organizaciones
feministas se congregaron A última hora
del martes a las puertas de la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos para
defender las libertades reproductivas de
las mujeres de la región unas protestas
enmarcadas en las audiencias de la corte
sobre el caso de Beatriz versus El
Salvador que empieza en este miércoles y
jueves Beatriz una joven de una zona
rural y empobrecida del Salvador tenía
Apenas 20 años cuando le diagnosticaron
lupus en 2011 tuvo un primer embarazo de
riesgo agravado por su enfermedad pero
su primer hijo logró sobrevivir tras más
de un mes internado Poco después volvió
a quedarse embarazada los doctores le
recomendaron no tener el niño que iban a
hacer con una malformación congénita sin
cráneo ni cerebro además la gestación
iba a afectar de manera severa su salud
tengo 22 años
y soy de Usulután le pido a al
presidente a Mauricio Funes que que me
ayude a que la sala acepte a interrumpir
el embarazo yo por todo esto que está
pasando Pues yo me siento mal pues
porque no quieren hacerlo pues
sabiendo que no no va a vivir el niño al
nacer pues sin embargo en un país donde
la vida se percibe desde la concepción y
el aborto está prohibido en cualquier
circunstancia Beatriz tuvo que seguir
adelante para evitar ser encarcelada el
bebé no superó el parto y ella cuya
salud quedó muy perjudicada tras el
embarazo terminó falleciendo en un
accidente de tráfico menor en América
Latina y el Caribe todavía hay cinco
países que prohíben la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo en todas las
causales en una región con muchas
beatrices ahora la Corte Interamericana
tiene en sus manos evaluar el caso y si
procede obligar al a cambiar su
legislación una decisión que todavía
tendrá que esperar hasta finales de año
visitamos ahora en Nueva York donde esta
semana se registraron manifestaciones de
Seguidores del expresidente Donald Trump
quien los convocó afirmando que iba a
ser detenido a pesar de que apenas se
iba a reunir el gran Jurado para decidir
si imputaba cargos o no en contra del
Magnate por presuntos sobornos para
silenciar a la actriz de cine para
adultos Story Daniels aún así podría ser
candidato para las elecciones de 2024
pues la Constitución estadounidense no
estipula prohibiciones para acusados ni
personas halladas culpables de algún
crimen durante sus más de 40 años de
vida pública Trump ha enfrentado varias
investigaciones Alba Santana nos cuenta
cuáles son
los problemas legales se acumulan en
torno al expresidente de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump Y aunque el más reciente ha
sido el más sonado Cuántas causas tiene
pendientes el republicano la última es
la de la actriz de la industria
pornográfica stormy Daniels a finales de
la campaña presidencial de 2016 Trump
habría mandado pagar
130.000 dólares a cambio de su silencio
sobre una aventura que mantuvieron años
atrás y aunque el pago no es ilegal per
se sí lo es si se considera que
favoreció su campaña política pero esta
no es la que más problemas le podría
causar al político conservador el asalto
al Capitolio El Seis de enero de 2021 se
saldó con una causa penal contra Trump
el motivo haber instigado a sorda de
Seguidores a actuar violentamente
acciones por las que el republicano fue
condenado en una investigación política
que recomendó condenarlo por cuatro
delitos
en paralelo a la investigación del
Capitolio el FBI incautó al menos 15
cajas con archivos al clasificados de su
residencia de Mara lago algo que podría
traerle problemas penales ya que según
expertos cualquier retención o
destrucción de documentos de la Casa
Blanca incurre en delito tras estas
polémicas llegó el caso contra su
empresa familiar la Trump organization
señalada por fraude fiscal hurto mayor y
falsificación de registros todo para
evadir impuestos de prebendas a altos
ejecutivos durante 15 años y resultó en
una investigación penal ya resuelta
contra el director financiero y otra
civil que pide 250 millones de dólares a
Trump y tres de sus hijos no obstante el
republicano sostiene que todas estas
causas tienen motivaciones políticas y
ya ha dicho que ninguna de ellas le hará
renunciar a presentarse a la presidencia
en 2024 el ministro de economía
argentino Sergio massa anunció la
intervención de la compañía eléctrica
edesur por los cortes masivos de energía
que se han producido en las últimas
semanas la intervención será por 180
días para certificar el cumplimiento de
las obras que debe efectuar edesur y
garantizar buen funcionamiento tras
pérdidas económicas y riesgos para la
salud debido a las interrupciones la
ciudad y la provincia de Buenos Aires
deberán asignar representantes al
proceso
y vamos a México el tribunal
internacional de los derechos de la
naturaleza que es una institución
establecida por ciudadanos para
investigar y dar a conocer las
violaciones a los derechos de la
naturaleza demandan que se detenga la
construcción del tren Maya la
deforestación de la selva la
contaminación del agua El despojo y la
expropiación de tierra son algunas de
las consecuencias que han enfrentado las
comunidades mayas desde que comenzaron
las obras del proyecto insignia del
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
el informe es de la corresponsal de
France 24 en español Katia Espinoza
Nelly Lleva más de 30 años dedicada a la
apicultura y es la primera vez que las
abejas no están siendo productivas no
hay duda las colonias están sufriendo
los efectos de la deforestación
ocasionada por la construcción del tren
maya en la selva de la Península de
Yucatán en el sureste mexicano qué es lo
que observamos las abejas tienen una
situación de yo les digo que están
desnutridas no tienen el mismo nutriente
no tiene la misma fuerza no tienen
la misma Vamos a decir que la energía
para reproducirse desde su inicio el
tren Maya ha enfrentado más de 25
amparos de asociaciones y organismos del
medio ambiente que buscan la suspensión
de la obra uno de los tramos más
polémicos es el cinco ubicado entre
Tulum y Playa del Carmen en el Estado
Sureño de Quintana Roo porque atraviesa
y amenaza largos tramos de Selva virgen
que han sido deforestados sistemas de
Cuevas que se han derrumbado con las
maquinarias y flujos hídricos que han
sido alterados he visto cenotes en los
que buceado que ya no existen este donde
estamos ahora
está condenado está moribundo
va a morir no hemos fallado en salvarlo
la selva que quitaron de aquí la selva
que yo conocí que estaba arriba este
cenote ya no está pues es del tribunal
internacional de los derechos de la
naturaleza constataron las violaciones
al medio ambiente y notaron la
afectación a cientos de especies que
viven aquí la selva maya
como que agoniza como que
dice pide auxilio pide auxilio al mundo
a los ecologistas a la comunidad
científica que intervenga y a las Cortes
internacionales para decir que pare esto
el gobierno de México con este proyecto
insignia intenta construir 1.550
kilómetros de vía de ferrocarril a
través de cinco estados del sureste del
país y su meta es inaugurado en
diciembre de 2023 desde grandes
depredadores como el jaguar Hasta los
más pequeños como las abejas están
resintiendo el atropello del tren que
aún no pasa pero que ya deja sentir sus
efectos gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión de aquí América por favor
envíenme sus comentarios a la dirección
que ven en su pantalla en la producción
estuvo Luis Fernando Montes pueden ver
esta emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web trans24.com
[Música]